on y
va en route pour Paris et son arc de
triomphe ce soir-là des jeunes de
Montini et voisins vont avoir le
privilège de participer à la cérémonie
du ravivage de la Flamme sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu c'est une cérémonie assez
importante à laquelle nous avons les
trois communes concernées
souhaité impliquer nos conseils
municipal des jeunes parce qu'il nous a
semblé que la mémoire elle doit se
transmettre se se raviver également et
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui nos conseils
municipal des jeunes sont présents c'est
waren cabéi ancien président du conseil
municipal des jeunes de Montini qui a
été choisi comme porte drapeau jeens que
c'est important pour toutes les
personnes qui sont là
c'est c'est une certaine fierté aussi
pour les élus de ma ville donc je suis
content de le faire c'est un moyen de se
rappeler qu'il y a eu la guerre et de se
rappeler qu'il y des gens qui sont morts
pour nous l'association des officiers de
réserve des Yvelines a effectué toute un
travail de préparation auprès de ces
jeunes à propos de la finalité de cette
cérémonie car la guerre de 141 pour
certains c'est un peu flou reste le
symbole moi je pense que c'est très
important exactement qu'on soit là en
tant que jeune qu'on existe en France
donc je pense que c'est un symbole fort
en tout 60 jeunes yvelinois venus de
Montini voisins et viroffl ont participé
à cette cérémonie le ravivage de la
Flamme a lieu tous les jours à 18h30
depuis 1923 en mémoire des soldats
français tombés pendant la guerre de